i don't want to cry
megan the stallion couldn't help but get
emotional after winning best new artist
at the 2021 grammys
making her the first female hip-hop
artist to win the category in
22 years lauren hill took home the honor
in 1999.
first of all i want to say everybody
is amazing every artist that was
nominated for this award
is so amazing at the top of her
acceptance speech meg acknowledged the
other best new artist contenders
doji cat the smoke noah cyrus ingrid
andrus
phoebe bridgers chica and katrinata she
went on to thank god
her team and her late mother and i
really want to say thank you to my mama
she's not here with me today but i know
she here with me in spirit
and she always believed i could do it so
thank you all so much
just before the show the houston rapper
opened up to et's kevin frazier
about what her mom would say about the
special night she definitely
we'll be in here crying we will be
crying together my makeup will be
terrible but i know she's proud
uh her and my dad so yeah just shout out
to my parents for
making me they believed your mama
believed and this is her
this is her mom she really guided me
here yeah yeah so
this is all dedicated to my mom tonight
earlier in the day meg won best rap
performance alongside beyonce for savage
remix
and the grammy goes to
savage megan the stallion featuring
beyonce
[Applause]
if you don't jump to put jeans
everybody in the room all my people in
the room
y'all thank you lord god is the first
person i want to thank oh my gosh
um my grandma thank you nami
for not you know making me stop music to
finish school
um thank you mama
for pushing me and knowing that i was
going to be here thank you beyonce
like i just i still can't even believe
this like what
what me just thank thank you hotties
thank you houston after a year of ups
and downs
megan told et what this award-winning
night symbolizes for her
i feel like 2020 was crazy for everybody
i know i had a lot going on in 2020 and
i just feel like this is a moment where
i'm like you know what you've been
through it
you went through it but you made it yeah
you did make it
i made it through and now i'm here i've
i've already won one grammy that's right
and
i'm just so appreciative like i'm so
humbled
like i don't i don't even know what to
say i'm just excited to be here